ist der mond ganz anders als gedacht und
vor allem deutlich jünger und auch
anders entstanden wort obwohl uns der
mond so nahe ist stellt der erdtrabant
für forschungsteams weltweit immer noch
ein großes rätsel dar
eine aktuelle studie offenbart jetzt
dass der mond voller metalle ist was
eigentlich nicht sein kann
eine weitere forschungsarbeiten liefert
hinweise darauf dass wir uns bei der
altersbestimmung des mondes lange zeit
getäuscht haben also wie und wann ist
der mond jetzt tatsächlich entstanden
diesen rätseln kommen wir in diesem
video auf die spur pixum tanzen future
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen und vielen dank für den
themenvorschlag von petra über unsere
dogan community der link zum newsfeed
dort ist hier unter me und in der video
beschreibung da bekommt ihr die videos
früher als hier auf youtube und bei
diesem video ist auch unseren gestirn
experte dabei tim von astro comics
cooler kanal unbedingt abonnieren der
link ist ebenfalls hier und der mond
birgt trotz intensiver forschung noch
zahlreiche geheimnisse obwohl er uns
verhältnismäßig nahe ist stellt der mond
also immer noch ein großes rätsel für
uns da rund 350 kilogramm mondgestein
wurden bereits zur erde gebracht doch
die lassen nur noch mehr fragen auf
kommt eine der großen bislang
ungeklärten fragen wann und wie genau
ist der mond entstanden und es gibt
weitere geheimnisse die noch ungeklärt
sind beispielsweise lässt dass mond
material darauf schließen dass der mond
mal ein sehr starkes magnetfeld gehabt
haben muss doch dafür müsste sein kern
eigentlich so flüssig sein wie der der
erde
doch das ist eher nach ansicht der
fachleute nummer nicht weitere große
rätsel kamen erst gerade wieder auf ist
der mond vielleicht doch tektonisch
aktiv lange zeit galt jedoch als toter
geologisch inaktiver himmelskörper klar
ist jedenfalls dass er einst vulkanisch
aktiv war das zeigen viele larven große
mit basalt gefüllte mond mehrere und
vulkane die sogar geologisch relativ
jung sind fachleute weltweit stoßen
immer wieder mal auf neue spektakuläre
erkenntnisse sowie nun auch ein us
forschungsteam die fachleute haben
nämlich herausgefunden dass der mond
voller metalle ist und das stellt alle
unseren bisherigen annahmen zum mond
entstehung in frage hinzu kommen viele
weitere offene fragen zu seiner
entstehung die eigentlich mit der
kommenden monate schon in vier jahren
2024 gelöst werden sollten doch hier
gibt es offensichtlich probleme wann und
wie werden wir unser mond also ein für
alle mal verstehen und seine geheimnisse
lüften auch die neuen erkenntnisse eines
forschungsteams aus münster und berlin
verdeutlich mal wieder wie wenig wir
wirklich über unseren mond wissen mit
hilfe eines numerischen modells gelang
es den forschenden die geburtsstunde des
mondes zu rekonstruieren diese fand
demnach später statt als bislang
angenommen
der trabant ist demnach nicht vor 4,51
milliarden jahren entstanden sondern vor
4,4 2 5 milliarden jahren heißt also im
klartext dass der mond fast 100
millionen jahre jünger ist als bisher
angenommen
die entstehung des mondes war nicht ohne
hierbei kollidierte die junge erde ja
wohl mit einem protoplaneten der etwa
die größe vermaß gehabt haben muss aus
diesen trümmern entstand dann der mond
so zumindest die bisherigen annahmen der
fachwelt wenn es tatsächlich so war muss
es sich um ein wirklich gigantisches
spektakel gehandelt haben bei der
kollision der beiden körper nämlich
wurde gestein aus dem früheren erdmantel
herausgeschleudert dieses sammelte sich
dann wohl in einem ring aus staub um die
erde bevor sich dann wieder zu gestein
zusammenballt manche fachleute
spekulieren dass daraus dann der mond
entstand und das in verhältnismäßig
kurzer zeit möglicherweise sogar nur
wenigen tausend jahren mehr zu den neuen
forschungsergebnissen jetzt von tim von
astro com ist ev dessen kanal ihr
definitiv mal vorbeischauen solltet ihr
wisst ja hier und ami bis jetzt rätselt
die fachwelt aber immer noch mehr oder
weniger verzweifelt über den zeitpunkt
der mond entstehung das autorenteam aus
münster und berlin nutzt jetzt eine neue
indirekte methode um mehr darüber
herauszufinden und zwar will man sich
den magma ozean des mondes zu nutze
machen denn genau wie die erde in ihrer
frühzeit besaß auch der mond einen magma
ozean der durch aktion zustande gekommen
ist fachleute bezeichnen den prozess als
attraktion bei dem die materie eines
kosmischen objekten
eingesammelt wird und dabei wird
gravitations energie in
strahlungsenergie umgewandelt und das
sehr effizient spricht die erde hatte
nach ihrer kollision mit einem
protoplaneten einen ring aus heißem
geröll und lava und steinchen und staub
und aus diesen bringen hat sich dann der
mond gebildet mehr als 40 prozent der
ruhe energie kann bei der aktion in
strahlungsenergie umgewandelt werden und
das führte dazu dass es auf dem mond an
ein bis zu 1000 kilometer tiefen magma
ozean gab der den mond fast vollständig
aufgeschmolzen hat auch an der
oberfläche des mondes also quasi an der
schnittstelle zum kalten weltraum
bildete sich quasi eine mondkruste aus
auf schwimmenden leichten kristallen
darunter aber blieb der magma ozean noch
für lange zeit bestehen doch wie lange
genau wie lange hat es gedauert bis der
magma ozean des mondes komplett
kristallisiert war
diese frage konnten fachleute lange
nicht beantworten und deswegen war es
eben immer unklar wann der mond sich
denn nun gebildet hatte die
forscherteams aus münster und berlin
konnten aber nun mit hilfe eines
computermodells genauere angaben über
die kristallisation des lunaren magma
ozeans machen dazu das autorenteam die
ergebnisse des modells zeigen dass der
magma ozean des mondes langlebig watt
und ist fast 200 millionen jahre dauerte
bis er vollständig zu mantel gestein
auskristallisiert die zeitskala ist viel
länger als in früheren studien berechnet
ältere modelle ging von einer
kristallisation dauer von nur 35
millionen jahren aus doch das war nur
der anfang ihrer forschungen um den
exakten zeitpunkt der entstehung des
mondes zu berechnen mussten sie auch
noch die eisen und magnesium haltigen
silikat minerale des mordes mit
einbeziehen wie hatten diese sich
während des kristallisation prozesses
des magma ozean verändert das ergebnis
eindeutig demnach veränderte sich der
magma ozean während des kristallisieren
prozess kontinuierlich
das autorenteam verbindet diese
erkenntnisse dann auch noch mit der
bildung verschiedener mondgestein zu
verschiedenen phasen des kristallisieren
prozesses des magma ozean es also eine
sehr um die ecke gedachte methode dazu
die wissenschaftlerin sabrina schwinger
durch den vergleich der gemessenen
zusammensetzung der mond
die steine mit der vorhergesagten
zusammensetzung des magma ozean unserem
modell konnten wir die entwicklung des
ozeans bis zu seinem ausgangspunkt den
entstehungs alter des mondes
zurückverfolgen und auf diese art und
weise gelang es dann also das alter des
mondes zu rekonstruieren
dazu der berliner forscher maxim maurice
das ergebnis unserer modellierungen legt
nahe dass die junge erde rund 140
millionen jahre nach der geburt des
sonnensystems vor 4,5 6 7 milliarden
jahren von einem protoplaneten getroffen
wurde
das geschah nach unseren berechnungen
von 4,4 2 5 milliarden jahren mit einer
unsicherheit von 25 millionen jahren
das war die geburtsstunde des mondes
demnach hatte unsere erde dann also auch
ihre entwicklung abgeschlossen heißt im
klartext und sei erdtrabant entstand
ganz am ende der entwicklung und dieses
ergebnis war selbst für fachleute eine
große überraschung
thorsten kleine von der universität
münster sagte dazu folgendes es ist das
erste mal dass das alter des mondes
direkt mit einem ereignis in verbindung
gebracht werden kann dass am ende der
erdstoß passierte der entstehung des
kerns der erde eine super spannende
forschung also die offenlegt wie wenig
wir trotz all unseren bemühungen über
unseren trabanten wissen
interessanterweise wurde gerade in
diesen tagen eine neue studie
veröffentlicht die unsere bisherigen
erkenntnisse über den mond noch mal
richtig auf den kopf stellt demnach
könnte alles ganz anders sein
insbesondere könnte die theorie dass die
erde mit den protoplaneten teac
validiertes und daraus eben schließlich
der mond entstand sich als überholt
erweisen hinweise darauf liefert der
sogenannte nasa lunar reconnaissance
orbiter lro dessen daten haben nämlich
zur überraschung der nasa fachleute
hinweise darauf geliefert dass der
mondstaub äußerst metallhaltige doch
woher soll dieser metallhaltige staub
auf dem mond kommt von der erde können
diese metalle jedenfalls nicht kommen
denn tatsächlich findet man so was hier
auf unserem planeten er im tieferen
schichten der erdkruste
wenn aber die erde mit thea kollidiert
wäre dann wären dabei nur die oberen
schichten in den weltraum geschleudert
worden so lässt sich das also nicht
erklären wie kann es also sein dass es
auf dem mond mehr eisenoxide im staub
gibt als auf der erde wie sind
da hingekommen die nasa hat genau diese
frage auf dem schirm und hat deswegen
die ergebnisse des miniatur
radiofrequenz instrumentes an bord des
lunar reconnaissance orbiters untersucht
dazu der nasa-forscher es energie
es ist möglich dass die diskrepanz
zwischen der eisen länge auf der
erdkruste und dem mond noch größer sein
könnte als von wissenschaftlern
angenommen was das derzeitige
verständnis der entstehung des mondes in
frage stellt konkret geht es um die
kraterlandschaft des mondes die durch
die einschläge von meteoriten verursacht
wird durch solche einschläge werden
materialien aus den unteren schichten
des mondes nach oben gedrückt und das
lässt sich dann super analysieren die
ergebnisse dieser analysen sind
eindeutig und zwar konnten die fachleute
in den tieferen krater an eine höhere
metall konzentration vorfinden als in
den flacheren in kleineren karten
doch warum ist der mond überhaupt voller
kristalle eine eindeutige antwort darauf
hat die nasa noch nicht doch es gibt
drei erklärungsmöglichkeiten demnach
könnte die kollision zwischen der frühen
erde und thea deutlich früher
stattgefunden haben als bislang
angenommen und zwar so viel früher dass
die erde noch von einem magma ozean
bedeckt gewesen sein muss also deutlich
jünger war als bislang angenommen
denn dann wäre es durchaus vorstellbar
dass flüssiges metall bei der kollision
in den weltraum gelangt ist zusammen mit
anderen materialien hätte es sich dann
zum heutigen montag banden gebildet eine
weitere erklärungsmöglichkeiten für die
hohe methankonzentration auf dem mond
könnte sein dass die kollision für die
junge erde sehr viel schlimmere folgen
gehabt haben könnte als wir bislang
angenommen haben viel tiefere abschnitte
und nicht nur die erdkruste wären in
mitleidenschaft gezogen worden und somit
in die umlaufbahn gelangt als dritte
mögliche erklärung könnte der hohe
metallgehalt auch mit einem
komplizierten abkühlung prozess der
geschmolzenen mondoberfläche begründet
sein ist also die noch heiße oberfläche
des mondes anders abgekühlt als wir es
bislang annehmen
die neuen ergebnisse waren zudem auch
eine andere hypothese wahrscheinlicher
nach der nämlich die erde
bei der kollision mit der komplet
verdampfte demnach könnte sich aus den
trümmern zu erst die erde und dann der
mond neu gebildet haben
fest steht dass weitere analysen
notwendig sind um dieses mysteriöse
rätsel
zu lösen das miniatur radiofrequenz
instrument des lunar orbiter wird also
weiterhin radarmessungen durchführen die
verantwortlichen der nasa sind
optimistisch und freuen sich das zitat
die lro mission uns immer wieder mit
neuen einsichten in die ursprünge und
die komplexität unseres nächsten
nachbarn überrasche es lässt sich also
festhalten dass zwei aktuelle studien
darauf hinweisen dass die mond
entstehung möglicherweise nicht nur zu
einem anderen zeitpunkt als bislang
gedacht stattgefunden hat auch der
ablauf der mond entstehung könnte sich
demnach möglicherweise anders zugetragen
haben
dafür sprechen die hohe metallgehalte in
den unteren schichten die kommenden
montag könnten jedenfalls dazu beitragen
die entstehung des mondes besser zu
verstehen und nicht nur die nasa und die
esa sondern auch china wollen zurück auf
den mond noch in diesem jahrzehnt sollen
wieder menschen dorthin fliegen und auch
für längere zeit dort bleiben eine
bemannte nasa mission könnte schon im
jahr 2024 auf dem mond landen und
möglicherweise eine mondstation beziehen
aber wer weiß als erster außenposten der
menschheit auf einem anderen
himmelskörper dazu der nasa
wissenschaftler james green geplant ist
dass 2024 eine bemannte landung auf dem
mond stattfinden soll diesmal soll aber
kein mann sondern eine astronautin
zuerst aussteigen insgesamt für das team
aus vier oder fünf astronauten bestehen
zwei oder drei auf dem mond einer oder
zwei in der umlaufbahn
doch die landung auf dem mond scheint
sich eben zu verschieben denn der nasa
fehlt es nicht nur an finanziellen
mitteln sondern auch an personal
mittlerweile geht selbst der us-kongress
medienberichten zufolge in seinen
haushaltsplanung frühestens vom jahr
2028 aus neue spannende erkenntnisse
gibt es auch über unsere nachbargalaxie
andromeda deren ausmaße noch die
gigantischer unvorstellbarer sind als
man ursprünglich annahmen um mehr
darüber zu erfahren schaut euch das
video hier von tim bei astro comics tv
an also anklicken anschauen und astro
comics tv auf jeden fall abonnieren team
braucht nur noch ganz ganz wenige abos
bis 30.000 vielleicht schaffen wir es ja
gemeinsam bis dann bleibt dran